hi everyone alex jen here so i'm going
to continue in this video talking about
training in a confined space
previously i talked about the bakken and
focused mainly on
strikes in this video i'm going to be
looking at
the joe and we'll be talking about
thrusts
and looking at how a confined space can
actually
help with your training
[Music]
to start with let's look at chocoski
which is a mid-level thrust a common
mistake
which some people make is when they're
in this ready position
they would actually draw their arm back
before
stepping forward and thrusting and
again another problem that people might
make is they might not draw their arm
back
but they actually step forward and then
thrust
now why why are these issues well the
first one
uh when we draw our arm back we're
actually wasting a movement here because
we're actually going backwards
to then go forwards which is a wasted
move
the second one although we're not moving
our arm we're actually
stepping forward we're planting our
weight in front which might be good for
stability but the problem is
is we're now leaving ourselves open for
an attack
before we move forward because the joe
is has still not actually
gone forward yet so we've got a little
bit of a problem there
so let's have a look at how we can fix
this if i use this door behind me
it could be a wall as well it doesn't
really matter but the thing is
i've got this object behind me which is
stopping me from moving my
arm backwards like that
i'm stood in this ready position with my
hand by my hip
the other hand is in the center of the
jaw in this position i want to be able
to advance forward
but without actually dropping my weight
forward so it's leaving me
open and then coming up so what i can do
is actually take a bit of what i'd call
an empty step
where i'm stepping but not actually
bringing my whole weight forward
as i do that and keep my hand this hand
fixed if you like
i'd go forward and then follow
up with the thrust behind so i'll show
you again
so in this position so as you can see
here the door actually stops me
from moving my arm back and then that
forces me to move forward
when thrusting i just need to be mindful
of not stepping forward
and planting my weight and leaving the
thrust behind so another thrust that'll
be useful to train against the wall is
kaiserski this is a reverse thrust where
we draw the
joe and thrust in this reverse grip so
our other hand is
turned outwards rather than being in
this position
the reason that the wall is useful in
this circumstance
is because it stops our arm drifting
across what i mean by that is a common
mistake is for people to do
this rather than move their body and
step offline
their arm moves across and what happens
if we do this
is it leaves our arm exposed
particularly your elbow
for for someone to do a counter thrust
or as they're moving in
to catch your your elbow as you move
offline
so a way to get around that is by
training against the wall
i'll show you what i mean so when i'm in
this position my elbow
is pressed up against the wall and this
is stopping me
moving my elbow across i then have to it
then forces me to move my body
offline i draw and thrust
okay so this is stops it moving
i keep it pressed against the elbow um
keep my
i keep my elbow pressed against the wall
draw
thrust
so as you can see here the wall actually
helps
by stopping my elbow move across the
line of attack
this rush can also be used moving side
to side and here where i've got the wall
and the chair again i'm confined in a
space
that's about that wide
it stops me moving my arm out
in this type of motion and what i need
to do is actually draw
through so these restrictions can really
help us refine our movements
and make sure that we're using our hips
correctly it makes sure that the
movements kept
nice and tight and that the joe isn't
drifting from
side to side the same exercise in terms
of keeping an alignment and working from
your hips
can be practiced by alternating from a
mid-level thrust to a high thrust
for your footwork you could either
alternate your stance or you could also
step forward if you have enough space
these can be linked together by changing
direction and going from a low thrust to
a high thrust
or vice versa you can also turn over the
joe to swap sides anyway i hope that
gives you some more ideas of what you
can possibly train inside
even if you have limited space i'd
really appreciate your thoughts and
comments on this
and as always please remember to like
share and subscribe as this helps the
channel grow
next time i'm going to be covering clubs
and having a look at what options
are available in a small space okay
until next time take care and i'll see
you soon